Before we dive in,
let me explain how I've organized
the topics of this course.
There are three major parts, or units.
These units reflect three different
ideas about what a computer looks like.
Now, to explain what that means,
let's go back to CS 101.
There you probably learned about a
machine model called the sequential, or
serial RAM model.
>> [MUSIC]
>> There's a single serial processor
connected to memory.
This processor issues instructions
that operate on data.
>> Still computing.
>> [MUSIC]
>> The operands of these
instructions always live in memory.
When you analyze the cost
of a serial ram algorithm,
you assume that all instructions have
a cost that is bounded by some constant.
Now from that starting point,
you do a big O style analysis
in terms of the input size.
So, that's the serial ram model.
I hope you already know it by heart,
and maybe even love it a little?
Now, what are the alternatives
to the serial RAM model?
Well, a first alternative is
the Parallel RAM or PRAM model.
Instead of one processor,
there may be many.
They all see the same memory, and
you still assume a bounded
constant cost per operation.
But you get to work with
more than one processor.
And since the processors all see
the same memory, they can coordinate and
communicate by modifying
shared variables.
Now in this model, your algorithmic
analysis will involve big O as before,
but you'll try to reduce the total
cost by up to a factor of P,
the number of processors.
A PRAM style model is arguably
the simplest one that you might use on,
say, a shared user multi-core
machine with uniform memory access.
Using a what's it?
Don't worry, you'll get there.
So that was one alternative.
Here's another,
a distributive memory network model.
It's basically just
an interconnected network of RAMS.
That is,
you start with multiple RAM computers.
Each computer has a processor
with its own private memory.
No processor can read or
write the memory of any other.
Instead, they join forces connecting
to one another over a network.
They coordinate by sending and
receiving messages over this network.
Now, in this model, your analysis will
count the number of messages, and
the total volume of communication.
Okay, now here's a third alternative
that we'll consider in this class.
It's a two-level input output,
or ("I/O") Model.
In this model, there are one or more
processors connected to a main memory.
It's sort of like RAM or PRAM, but you
assume that there's at least one level
of fast memory that sits in between the
processors and the slower main memory.
This model forces you to think
about the following question.
How much data needs to move from memory
to the processor using this small,
but fast,
intermediate memory as scratch space?
Now, if you know about
things like caches or
virtual memory, then you might
already know this basic model.
But even if that's the case,
do you also know how to design
algorithms that exploit it?
So, to recap,
we will discover the big ideas of this
course using three machine models.
PRAM, the distributive memory, or
network model, and the two-level, or
I/O, model.
So, with that as background,
I think we're finally ready to start.
Woot!